Be like American idol auditions. I
would be crazy than that. It'd be that.
Have you seen that? A Guatemalan
volcano eruption? Have you seen that?
Where people are running from the smog?
It's fucking crazy girls.
Guys like that much pussy coming
down the mountain headed towards you.
It's, it's that Guatemala
eruption is fucking scary man.
There's nothing like that in, in comedy
other than Chris Delea. Yeah, he's close.
He's close.
But even looking at us Guatemala,
most violent eruption in more than a
hundred years, 25 people already dead.
And just, I think it just happened
yesterday. It's fucking crazy, man.
Dozens of people have died after erupted.
Yeah. Sunday is getting back at us, dude.
That's too right. Hawaii and this one,
I mean we gotta be real fucking careful.
Surprise. New Zealand hasn't
had a couple of options.
Did they have like a live volcano in New
Zealand? I just know that. I think I,
can you double check fact check this,
but I think New Zealand has the
most volcanoes in the world. What?
I was just the air those tours
and they're like, you know,
what'd you do over there? Well,
I want you to cook islands. Ooh,
Captain Cook Islands and the
Cook Islands pirates showed up.
Beautiful vacation and
there's no Americans,
which is what I love you and I can't get,
I can't stand going someplace
and it's just all American.
Like I don't go to answer Nada, you
know, go to Venice beach. You know, I,
I don't want to be around
the same time Maui is. Yeah.
Yeah. I don't like going to,
while he's basically Beverly Hills,
Beverly hills gone fall.
Kaino map of New Zealand. Jesus
Christ. He's fucking fault.
You know, one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight,
nine, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14,
15, 16, 17, 18 volcanoes
that right. You're like,
you can't lie on this show because this
guy's going to fact check you right away.
That is insane. But I'm telling you
right now, beautiful vacation. Oh, I bet.
I didn't like actually like do Zealand,
like I went to Oakland,
I thought I'm driving around downtown
La. Oh, like cs or something.
I didn't like to sit down, not a
city guy. I liked this kind of shit.
Like outdoors nature of beaches. Yeah.
Well, the nature of their stunning,
I want to look out my hotel window and
the sliding door and like there's sand
and then like the water's like
right there. Or mountains.
Yeah, he exact something.
Rain forest,
something,
something that's different from this
urban jungle that we live in all the time.